the Joe Rogan experience now what about
food like what what kind of diet are you
guys on mmm we all basically the exact
same thing you know just a ton of meat
and rice and we do a lot of peppers and
stuff like that no one's vegan no no no
that one guy that Patrick with the foxes
name there's a vegan strongman I've
heard of I don't remember his name but
he's not like he's never been the
World's Strongest Man well there's
there's a documentary they doing with
James Cameron where they're trying to
promote him as be gems cameras on this
vegan kick mmm-hmm his wife has a school
and they feed the kids all vegan food
and Arnold's a part of this too and
there yeah that guy yeah yeah yeah I
know who that is
he's not one of the strongest men in the
world he's a strong Landon he's strong
and I've said no disrespect I'm not I'm
not I'm not saying anything bad about
him he's just put that back up again Jim
he's just he's I don't and from what I
recall he's never even been invited
towards dogs man
so it's [ __ ] yeah I mean you can say
a lot of things like this guy say say he
broke a record in in like some
powerlifting competition that was in a
guy's backyard right and they call that
a world record and then all of a sudden
now he's a world record strength athlete
because his buddy in his backyard said
so a lot of that happens I don't know
specifically about him I've no no clue
where he's getting his his uh his
credentials from one meal a day see this
is ridiculous one meal a day and vegan
vegan professional power lifter to 13
2013 set the deadlift world record for
his weight class Oh
672 pounds for how much does he weigh
though there's 672 isn't even big for
guys that are like a hundred and fifty
well he's only five seven okay so he's
smaller than me so they're talking about
powerlifting to see once you get into
powerlifting there's so many little
Federation's and stuff like that
everybody and their mother has World
Records and just listen man so this
documentary is touting because that's
how I was confused like all the strong
men that I've seen are giants right
right like how can a five seven guy can
I've never seen them anyway
others on the circuit or anywhere and
there is a circuit like confirmed
circuit with guys like you who withdraw
yeah Eddie hall and Nick best we have
humans yeah we have the we have Giants
live Giants live is the qualifying tour
for world Strongest Man so to get to
Giants live you either there's like a
bunch of little Federation's that you
could possibly do well in and they'll
invite you or you know like getting
invited is kind of like the only tricky
thing get getting in but once you get
there if you prove yourself you get top
three or if like say you go to my first
Giants live I went to it was like
stacked like it was ten of the strongest
men on the planet and normally Giants
live has like three of the top ten and
then a few of other guys trying to get
in and so when I went it was topped all
the top ten guys and I got a sixth place
I believe but I still got a mud of the
world Strongest Man because it was the
top 10 strongest men in the world there
when I did that so normally you have to
go to a Giants live prove yourself there
and then you get invited to world
Strongest Man
sometimes like we've had years where
world Strongest Man got pushed and was
filmed early so they had to invite other
guys but you can you can always tell who
strong like you you can see when I guy
shows up and and he's ready to go or if
he's just got show muscles or if he's
just a big chubby dude you know and it's
it's I mean you strap a guy to a truck
and tell him to pull it 30 meters you're
gonna figure that [ __ ] out real quick
yeah [ __ ] show for some people
well they because the James Cameron
thing they're pulling this guy out as if
he's some world record power lifter
strongman guy he probably has mastered
he probably has some type of world
record I I've seen him because I've
posted videos talking about my meals and
stuff before and a lot of people give me
that like this guy does this and he's
vegan but I've I mean if the biggest
poll he's ever pulled is 627 that that
wouldn't even do like that would get
last place at an amateur heavyweight
show in America but also the other thing
is is Americ
we have way of the strongest men in the
world - like everyone it's weird in
America we have these people like have
these this love for other countries
everyone wants to be like well here in
Iceland they're really strong or oh and
Poland they're this and it's like
[ __ ] we're strong here like
we're [ __ ] strong hey if you're an
American getting in the world is the
hardest way to get in is if you go to
another country it's much easier much
easier because here we've got out of the
top ten we've probably got four or five
guys four or five guys that are top ten
in the world at any given time and only
like three or four maybe five guys get
invited every year from America so if
you're if you're getting in the world's
you've got to be a bad [ __ ] or
go move to Poland or actually Poland's
got a bad dude right now Go Go move to
Lithuania or go go somewhere else lately
be easier because you'd represent a
country with a smaller talent pool yeah
much easier now what about when I hang
out here I believe
[Applause]